[Musique]
placez le dialogue et les échanges au
coeur de la réforme des territoires
le président de la république emmanuel
macron 1 réunies au sénat tous les élus
des collectivités territoriales nassimah
dindar a bien sûr fait le déplacement
pour le département les réformes sont
nécessaires et chaque acteur local doit
pouvoir y participer à sa façon le
président macron a réaffirmé ou bonne
idée celle de permettre à chaque
département ou région d'expérimenter
d'avoir une approche précise par rapport
aux problématiques sogeti nous demain
également
bien évidemment pour l'année 2010 est de
faire nous mêmes des économies ce qui
n'est pas une bonne nouvelle en disant
qu'effectivement après 2018
il y aura des réajustements qui seront
possibles pas de coupes en 2017
mais des possibilités de faire malgré
tout de la mutualisation des projets de
développement c'était à metz
au final de faire des économies c'est
donc bien un processus de dialogue entre
l'état les collectivités territoriales
qui démarre le premier ministre l'a
affirmé aucune décision affectant les
collectivités locales ne soient prises
sans y être discutée cinq chantiers ont
été définis structure compétences pas
que financier lutte contre la fracture
territoriale et pour la complémentarité
des territoires et enfin contribution à
la transformation écologique et à la
mutation numérique de la france dans ce
climat de tension des collectivités
locales inquiètes pour leurs finances la
réunion subit un contexte particulier
car réduire le coût des prestations
sociales demeurent difficiles
le département de la réunion nous sommes
confrontés à des dépenses sociales qui
augmente principalement pour les
allocations a dit
elle de céder d'arrêter dont fait partie
le rsa puisque notre rsa continue à
augmenter puis la paix à l'allocation
personnalisée à l'autonomie pour les
personnes âgées je préfère moi pour la
réunion que les trains recentralise de
rs ap
puisque c'est vrai que s'il fallait
compenser les sommes seraient très
importante pour nous et déjà l'année
dernière nous n'avons pas obtenu les
compensations nécessaires
alors moi je proposerai au président de
la république que paie la réunion et
rapidement nous puissions envisager la
recentralisation du rsa par l'état pour
les collectivités l'effort doit
principalement venir de l'état sur les
trois dernières années elles ont réalisé
34 % d'économie à l'échelle de toutes
les dépenses nationales alors que 80% de
la dette est de la responsabilité de
l'état après le départ du président de
la république et les élus se sont réunis
au sein d'ateliers thématiques liées aux
fractures territoriales à paris nassimah
dindar s'est donc posé en interlocutrice
privilégiée face à l'état pour l'avenir
de ligne prochaine conférence des
territoires dans six mois
[Musique]